buddy welcome back I have terrible news
just as small there was a small
technical glitch it's just small so
we're gonna have to restart the show I'm
sorry
hang in there our next presenter
actually is a beautiful actress who
speaks four languages and earlier
tonight she taught me the phrase I'm
calling security in all of them please
welcome Academy Award nominee Penelope
Cruz
good evening it's time for the Foreign
Language Film Award congratulations to
all our nominated countries the nominees
are Beaufort from Israel
Joseph Seaver The Counterfeiters from
Austria Stefan rusev it's key katene Ian
from Poland and read vitae Mongol from
Kazakhstan Sergei Bodrov 12 from Russia
Nikita Mikhalkov and the Oscar goes to
Austria for The Counterfeiters accepting
the director Stefan do sobieski
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Austria
thank you very much
they have been some great Austrian
filmmakers working here thinking of
Billy Wilder Fred cinnamon Otto
Preminger most of them had to leave my
country because of the Nazis so it sort
of makes sense that the first Austrian
movie to win an Oscar is about the Nazis
crimes making this movie I had a most
brilliant cast a wonderful crew the best
of our families to support me at home so
actually it was easy for me thank you
very much